what we're going to do in this video is
look at all of the ways of describing
how to translate a point and then to
actually translate that point on our
coordinate plane so for example they say
plot the image of point p
under a translation by
five units to the left
and
three units up
so let's just do that at first and then
we're gonna think about other ways of
describing this
so we want to go 5 units to the left so
we start right over here we're going to
go 1 2
5 units to the left
and then we're going to go 3 units up
so that's going to be
one
two three and so
the image of point p i guess would show
up right over here after this
translation described this way
now there are other ways that you could
describe this translation here we
described it just in plain english by 5
units to the left and 3 units up but you
could and this will look fancy but as
we'll see it's hopefully a pretty
intuitive way to describe a translation
you could say look i'm going to take
some point with the coordinates x comma
y
and the x coordinate tells me how what's
my coordinate in the horizontal
direction to the left or the right and
so i want that to be 5 less so i would
say x
minus 5
comma
y and what do we do the y coordinate
well we're going to increase it by three
we're gonna translate three units up
so y
plus three so all this is saying is
whatever x and y coordinates you have
this translation will make you take 5
from the x that's what meaning this is
this right over here
is 5 units
to the left
and then this right over here is saying
three
units
up
increase your y coordinate by three
decrease your x coordinate by five and
so let's just test this out with this
particular coordinate with this
particular point so in this point right
over p has the coordinates its x
coordinate is 3 and its y coordinate is
negative 4. so let's see how that works
if i have 3 comma negative 4 and i want
to apply this translation what happens
well let me just do
my coordinates and so i started off with
3 and negative 4
and i'm going to subtract 5 from the 3.
so
subtract 5 here we see that right over
there and we're going to add 3
to the y so notice we're instead of an x
now i have a 3 instead of an x now i
have a 3 instead of a y now i have a
negative 4 instead of y now i have a
negative 4. and so another way of
writing this
we're going from 3 comma negative 4 to
3 minus 5 is negative 2 and negative 4
plus 3 is negative 1.
so what are the coordinates right over
here well the coordinate of this point
is indeed negative 2 comma negative 1.
so notice how this because you could say
this formula
the algebraic formula that shows how we
map our coordinates how it's able to
draw the connection between the
coordinates and so you'll see questions
where they'll tell you hey plot the
image and they'll describe it like this
translate x units to the left or the
right or three units up or down you'll
sometimes see it like this but just
recognize this is just saying take your
x and subtract 5 form it which means
move 5 to the left and this just means
take your y coordinate and add 3 to it
which means move 3 up
and sometimes they'll ask you hey what's
the new coordinate or sometimes they'll
ask you to plot something like that but
just realize that it's all the same
underlying idea